Mao Zedong once we lived 10,000 years in
1966 Mao tse-tung's had a problem the
Chinese leader who had led a peasant
army to victory in the Chinese Civil War
and established the communist People's
Republic of China in 1949 was getting
old worse his radical policies had
devastated the country and triggered the
deadliest famine known to human history
by the early 1960s mouths once great
influence and public presence were at an
all-time low and there were rumors that
he was dying or even dead already
he needed to find a way to seal his
legacy as the face of Chinese communism
and a new revolution to lead it started
in a river
the Great Leap Forward was a disaster it
was mouse a 1958 plan to quickly
industrialized China by working its
massive peasant population non-stop he
promises to transform the People's
Republic into an instant paradise
through the sheer force of numbers
forcing workers in the countryside to
farm crops on government-run communes
and millions more to manufacture crude
steel in homemade blast furnaces and
even though mao told the world that the
plan was succeeding everywhere the
Communists report production records are
being broken the truth was much more
desperate they flood the fields exhaust
the soil and farm production instead of
going up goes down the Chinese people
were being forced to work tirelessly on
land they once owned themselves and they
were starting to lose morale and despite
reports of widespread famine with
millions of people starving to death
Mao kept production quotas high
[Music]
ceaselessly without rest one observer
writes the countryside is in convulsion
Mao's Great Leap Forward ended in 1962
by that time somewhere between 23 and 55
million people had died in the famine
over the Soviet Union a different
political upheaval was happening Soviet
leader Joseph Stalin who Mao modeled
himself after was dead and now watched
as Nikita Khrushchev Stalin's successor
implemented a period known as
de-stalinization where Khrushchev set
out to reverse many of Stalin's policies
and dismantle the personality cult that
had formed around him Mao saw his own
legacy potentially suffering the same
fate his communist revolution was long
over and his ideas weren't taken as
seriously after the disaster of the
Great Leap Forward he was starting to
look like mouse place in the pantheon of
powerful communist figures like Vladimir
Lenin and Karl Marx was in peril
this is where the river comes in Mao had
a reputation for being a strong swimmer
and even used it as a symbol of his
ideology in 1956 he swam across China's
biggest river the Yangtze in three
highly publicized swims to demonstrate
that big things like US imperialism
didn't intimidate him ten years later
Matt took on the Yangtze again to dispel
rumors of his failing health this time
with cheering crowds swimming alongside
him he brought his personal photographer
who snapped this photo of the aging
dictator in the river and another one
showing Mao waving to his fellow
swimmers with the landmark Wuhan Yangtze
River bridge behind him an iconic
architectural achievement of the
communist government and proof that he
was at the Yangtze the swim made the
front page of China's State newspaper
reporting that Mao's swam around 15
kilometers a little more than nine miles
in a span of 65 minutes which meant the
72 year old would have shattered world
speed records a lot of people outside of
China laughed at the outlandish story
but some saw the swim for what it was a
sinister sign pointing out that Mao's
swims from a decade earlier preceded the
catastrophic Great Leap Forward experts
feared that Mao was on the verge of
kicking off another disastrous period of
turmoil in China they were right
two months before the swim Mao had
announced the beginning of his great
proletarian Cultural Revolution a call
to hunt down and eliminate the
bourgeoisie who had sneaked into the
party basically to purge the government
of anyone who strayed from principles of
Maoism and it kicked into high gear
after his historic swim which prompted a
craze for swimming in China but more
importantly a craze for Mao especially
among the group that Mao wanted to
influence the most China's youth writer
liang hang recalled that seeing Mao as
human flesh and blood after the Yangtze
swim resolved him to serve Him with all
his heart millions of Chinese youth
organized into the fanatical Red Guards
a paramilitary force concentrated mostly
in Chinese cities and with Mao's
blessing they wreaked havoc in the name
of Cultural Revolution their mission was
to destroy the four olds the idea was
basically to tear down the vestiges of
Imperial China and rewrite history
centered around mouse a tongue renaming
buildings and streets destroying
cultural sites and violently humiliating
and often torturing and murdering anyone
they accused of opposing Mao's ideas
which they plastered all over the cities
and carried in their pockets in the form
of Mao's little red book a collection of
his sayings and principles and although
the violent Red Guards were basically
dissolved by 1969 the Cultural
Revolution is considered to have
continued until Mao's death in 1976
ending a decade of destruction that had
elevated the leader to godlike levels
and resulted in over 1 million people
dead the chaos of the Cultural
Revolution scarred China for generations
but Mao basically got what he wanted
even though the Chinese Communist Party
condemned the Cultural Revolution in
1981 and Chinese communism diverted away
from maoism they didn't announce Mao
himself the Cultural Revolution
solidified maus cult of personality and
that influence has lasted
mouse swim which is still commemorated
each year in China was more than a
display of strength it was a message to
get behind Mao as he began his last
revolution
[Music]